call again hello felix gary vayner you
know this guy no i got him on my tic toc
feed i don't know what he does he just
speaks a lot and it's weird to listen to
why don't we start by watching some
advice that he gives oh it's this guy
yeah i've seen this dude yeah he looks
like he's 20 and 50 at the same time
that's what entrepreneur [ __ ] does to
you ken who do you love the most in the
world
my
family good who in your family pick one
all of them
every day make in the in like literally
today
genuinely sit there for five minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face
[Music]
that leads to the biggest happiness i
have
that's the biggest thing he does you
just gotta
i wasn't expecting that that was good
that's some deep knowledge man
thank you garyvee i will consider this
wow i've never just sat and thought
about people in my family getting
just shot in the face
it's funny because i think this is a
method of therapy of trying to cope with
bad things happening is envision them
but is it so funny saying that they got
shot in the face it's so awful
why would you say that
i don't know i figured like some pr
person would have pulled them aside and
been like i don't think this is the best
way to present this
just saying to be fair he mentioned
afterwards this is out of context or
something like that i just want to be
fair
the thing with this guy is that he loves
the sound of his voice i don't know how
what his net worth is he made some money
somehow i don't know and now he's just
gone into like monetizing being rich
basically to the point where like
anything he says he thinks is
interesting right well i mean there's
there's no better advice than advice
from
a wrench guy
here's here's some advice from rich from
rich guy everyone swallow every piece of
gum
i've swallowed every piece of gum that
i've ever chewed in my life
i don't think it's cool or anything i
don't think it's been
amazing it's just the truth i think it's
efficiency i don't think i want to give
up the 100th of a second putting in a
napkin just
swallow that [ __ ]
i'll take it back i'll take it back
maybe maybe not all advice from rich
people
that's gonna be stuck in the stomach for
seven seven years what are you doing
this guy is on such a level of
efficiency that that to do this
it's just not worth it for him it's
taking too much time he's joking right
there's no way he's serious by the way
right
he's got to be
marketing genius what a play he made
into the video he made it to a pewdiepie
video he did it yeah no but i guess this
is a holish stick but but a lot of
people swear by this guy they're like
they they treat him like they're god his
god like uh
they're his guru his mentor oh well has
he given some good advice is that uh
we'll see i mean here's some advice for
youtubers oh he's got youtube advice all
right advice every youtuber should have
heard before starting their channel i'm
at 142 what's one tip you have for kids
my age what do you want to happen cj
just to inspire people if you want to
inspire people if that's really what
you're about then you don't need to do
anything but continue to put out the
content that you think will do that
whether they're 13 or 81 so many people
get into the rat race of how many
followers they have and like that's just
not the game that you want to play you
can't let your self-esteem or self-worth
be wrapped up into metrics on youtube
because it's one tiny proxy in the
reality of what you're up to what's the
name of your channel cj cj bowling spell
it
c-j-b-o-l-i-n-g slower because you want
them to actually follow you
it would really mean a whole lot to me
if i've given you one inch of value ever
in my life for you to follow this kid
let's let's see how many followers he
has on youtube by the end of this
weekend
you just went away everything you just
said what do you
mean followers doesn't matter don't
worry about it kiddo anyway let's see
how many followers we can get this child
that would be epic you're gonna love me
so much
at this room right now right
he's just one of those people that says
so many things i used to some walk in
contradiction with everything well the
advice he was given wasn't like
completely horrible though by being
caught up in the whole system he just
goes to show that he doesn't give a [ __ ]
what he's saying he just says whatever
he thinks is going to make people feel
good and then he goes and contradicts it
blatantly because then that also would
make people feel good look he got all
his followers like brooch for breakfast
nothing i don't eat breakfast the
propaganda around breakfast being the
most important meal is propaganda from
the cereal and dairy industry it's not
true oh
actually we have been crushed oh
and grape nuts are my three favorite
cereals actually breakfast
that's so interesting tell us more about
how you don't eat breakfast
so tell me garyvee do you wipe facing
forward or backward it's propaganda it's
propaganda this toilet paper is
propaganda okay just splash your [ __ ]
with the water and soap idiot i mean i
don't eat breakfast either but that's
not because it's propaganda i'm just not
hungry in the morning that's all it is
for me bro anytime i'm hungry in the
morning i just go it's just propaganda
bro
you're being marketed
it's not even healthy it's not the most
important meal of the day
look bro i don't even like cinnamon
toast crunch actually okay i said it
uh that means nothing to me i don't know
what that is so sure
cereal cinnamon toast can cinnamon toast
crunch
what
oh my god you're a lie you're you're
like garyvee you're just like i'm just a
big lie about everything look whenever
they put me on the front of a cereal box
maybe i'll like it the most maybe then
yeah then no no free marketing for me
your cereal sucks damn
it sounds good though i'll eat it
pretty good smells pretty good it's not
my favorite i feel like i need some
background on this guy he's a belarusian
entrepreneur co-founder of the
restaurant restaurant services software
the restaurant reservation software yeah
when you book a table i guess
i love this simple ventures like
lemonade stand bro like that had
anything to do with it
yeah when i was a kid i sold seashells
on the street do you think i'm gonna
equate my youtube success to that
well it's i started young where felix
you sold hot dogs at one time i'm proud
of you that's how you
have nothing to do with it you're
building blocks success i'm curious what
do you think of this uh i have a
question about passive income and i want
to know what kind of trends do you see
when you say passive income do you mean
some what do you mean
i mean not having to work
all day long
our passive income is kind of definition
office in sweden
are you being serious right now
yes yes i'm serious
the quickest way to not be on a beach in
mexico
is to think that passive income exists
it's not real bro just like breakfast
isn't real it just doesn't exist you're
fool
the reason so many scum buckets are
making so much money is because you're
buying stupid [ __ ] courses over and
over thinking there's some [ __ ] magic
formula for passive income right that's
that's your whole shtick
what do you mean
the only
you're literally the definition of these
people that got rich by some chance and
then you're making your whole career
about talking about how justifying it as
everything you say now has value because
you you made it you made some money now
that this video is making passive income
you know by you know people watching it
over and over again yeah
he had to make that video to begin with
so it's not passive
okay exactly
oh god keep watching income looks like
this you take money that you can afford
to go to zero and you put them into two
places that have historically created
passive income
public markets that you don't care if it
goes up and down and you just wait to
the end or real estate and you hope that
your real estate area doesn't get
crushed
so there are there are passive incomes
okay cool let's just check in it does
exist
nice amazing thank you and thank you
garyvee those are two of the ways but
you know
not much of an investment guy can tell i
don't know i feel like he was like
probably a motivational speaker after he
made money because people were listening
to him because he made money and then he
had some nuggets of knowledge that like
trended and like gathered a following
and now he can pretty much just like
spit out anything people are like yes
that is right passive income doesn't
exist unless it's one of these two forms
which the guy was asking about trends
within those two things but
he did a great job at really
yeah and like not answering the
questions he does that a lot
make money raise money want to get
donations for charity
smart results
turn your netflix off
he basically says you want to be
successful stop watching netflix turn
that
that's it that's all you got to do but i
can't gary you don't understand how
difficult that is
it's too hard man i have to watch
selling sunset season three what the
[ __ ]
midnight mass every end of every episode
it's like play the next episode and i'm
like
oh man it was a great show i loved that
heck yeah the monologues were so long
but yeah it was good oh i'm sorry that
you hate good writing
dude they would sit there and just
preach the person for like 20 minutes to
fill their hour time slide they could
just
it was like it was like going to reading
the reddit i'm 14 and this is deep half
the time
what happens when i die it's funny
because i know exactly what student
you're talking about
man i i loved it but it's just like
me and mary were sitting there watching
one and we just like looked at each
other like how long has this been going
on
it keeps going oh it's it's their turn
now okay all right and now we get a
reply
like why don't you do this let me give
you my entire backstory yeah
i thought it i thought it was good i
still enjoyed it
no i didn't why are we talking about
we're talking about garyvee stop
focusing on thumbs ken like we're doing
but what is that what is the dumb [ __ ]
oh okay so he does these uh garage sale
videos which are really funny would you
consider five for this no
silence is a huge negotiation tactic and
in that silence they have to now start
thinking and they have to decide if they
want to get rid of it eight
eight is worth it right off the bat we
got them we paid eight for this vintage
budweiser flight that's a that's a 50
profit right off the bat
that's sick 50 dollars
by my evaluation this is at least fifty
dollars we did it
it's like those uh the shows that they
have where they go and like go through
people's stuff and they're like oh yeah
this
this vintage
is definitely worth at least eight
hundred dollars says
i have 150 in my wallet right now thanks
to this legendary purchase silence the
powerful tool now they have to think
about if they actually want to sell it
and then i paid more for it
got him
well i guess the thing is like a lot of
it is uh harmless
whatever doesn't matter but then he has
some really like toxic advice as well
about you need to just shut the [ __ ] up
and work and not do anything for 10
years that's his advice basically truth
behind becoming a millionaire
in less than eight years when i'm a
millionaire by 25 i'll come shake your
hand i promise you that statement itself
made me 100 guarantee that you won't
if you really want to win and you want
to come to new york in eight years and
shake my hand here's what you need to do
you need to stop giving a [ __ ] about
what anybody else has and realize that
if you put your head down and just work
for the next 10 years no glamour no new
car suitcase jewelry trip event no
coachella no [ __ ] new thing sneakers
like [ __ ] work you will have it and
every time you care about one of the
things i just mentioned it will slow
down your process of having it this is
the most
it's so mind-bogglingly stupid this
statement because first is doing this
toxic thing that all you need to focus
on is work for 10 years and that's all
you should be doing otherwise you're not
gonna get it but then he's he doesn't
realize that he's saying that they sh in
the process of becoming rich making
money so you can uh get all this uh
luxuries you need to completely ignore
it and and not care about it but it's
like if you do that then you don't need
it
to begin with
it's like your life bar in dark souls or
demon souls yeah you have this full life
bar and you fight the tutorial boss and
it goes down to nothing because you
don't need it and then
it gives you more but you don't need it
because that makes it good i didn't
expect this analogy but yeah
well the other thing about like becoming
a millionaire like okay we don't need to
like spend your money you gotta save
every bit of money you know in the
scheme of a million dollars the 100 pair
of shoes that you could have bought you
know when you needed them five years ago
okay
like
how's that that's not making a big
splash in your budget you know i don't
know maybe not maybe not i guess my my
point is like waste 10 years of your
life a huge portion of your life to then
just buy into the thing that you were
you taught yourself for 10 years to not
buy anything what the [ __ ] is the point
then of becoming a millionaire well then
your futures then you but then you can
be like me garyvee and tell people stuff
and they will listen
i'll tell them about me not even
breakfast i like the way he speaks too
like there's no like there's no dead
time and there's no going um it's you
just say
yeah
that's true that's that's his thing
we've got charlie and uh always son in
philadelphia
i eat stickers all the time dude
what i mean oh there's ads on your
videos gary v that's passive income
oh here's a great clip of him kissing
his dad for some reason i was looking at
wacky that he did and this is what i
found
all right go listen
all right let's go ahead let's go
you kiss your dad like damn you kiss
your dad like that
damn i thought whoa
i mean
more power too but i wasn't expecting
that that was that was passionate
why does he kiss his dad on his left
side
i'm so confused i mean i feel awkward
giving my my dad a hug guys go to 7 30
29 crazy life advice beat me 4 billion
in 6 days
oh my god i know who he is i know why he
seems so familiar
he is literally the embodiment of every
piece of unsolicited advice i've ever
gotten in the comment section
that's it if i was over playing a game
you know playing something and i'm gonna
pass something important he would be
down there like oh my god i can't
believe you know what you should do you
need to go back and play this game for
10 years nothing else but this game at
this game here's what you gotta do oh
god it's so lame it's the dumbest like i
feel like so many young people aspire to
be like young entrepreneurs and they
don't know how and they desperately you
know read all these rich people's books
and they purchase all these programs and
i'm sure there are some key elements to
becoming successful like work hard blah
blah blah be smart or whatever but at
the end of the day you can't sell the
formula because it's different for
everyone everyone that made money did it
in a different way and it it and a lot
of it that they don't even want to say
is that a lot of it also comes down to
luck and timing like if you and i
started doing youtube channels now it'd
be way [ __ ] different but we're not
gonna go around and tell people like all
you gotta do is what i did i sold hot
dogs all i did was grind i was like yeah
there's a lot of work and hard effort
and people know that but that's not only
the thing this is the netflix that you
need to turn off okay
you know that you know there's a secret
to being successful on youtube and
everyone always asks for it but we're
never going to tell you it's our secret
we don't want you to be big
[Laughter]
so i guess to some right i don't sure
some of it is harmless but a lot of it
is stupid toxic and i disagree with it
and i don't like him it is funny to
watch very funny i enjoy it anyway
that's garyvee for you subscribe for
more epic videos see you guys tomorrow
you okay shut up
thank you happy birthday